must be a busy week for Baroness Evans
the leader of the House of Lords the
upper house once again finds itself
making headlines for all the wrong
reasons this morning and on Tuesday the
brexit bill will reach the chamber for
two days of debate let's speak now to
Baroness Evans who joins me from our
central London studio badness Evans good
to see you the EU withdrawal bill heads
to the Lord's this week what are the
chances it returns to the Commons in one
piece oh I think there's every chance it
will return to the Commons in one piece
the House of Lords has taken a very
constructive role to the brexit
legislation we've had so far I mean for
instance we passed the article 50 bill
now don't get me wrong that doesn't mean
we won't be having detailed debates
there won't be challenges and the
government has said we're very welcome
we will be listening to constructive
suggestions but we will get the bill
through I'm confident of that well it
does seem like list that it's actually
after the second reading that we're
going to see the problems in the Lord
particularly on the the Henry the 8th
powers you know workers and fundamental
rights you know the devolve provisions
affecting you know Holyrood amongst
other places now if their Lordships act
as they say they do and push on these
amendments I mean that is precious
little you can do about it well as I've
said we're expecting strong debate I
mean the House of Lords is a
scrutinizing and revising chamber that's
its job so four things you're describing
is the Lord's doing its job I'm
expecting a very constructive discussion
you know where the Lord's come up with
suggestions to improve the bill the
government have said we're willing to
listen and we've also said that we
ourselves will be bringing forward
amendments particularly around for
instance the devolved issues that you've
mentioned so I'm expecting long debates
detailed debates but I'm also expecting
a constructive attitude and the laws to
do its job and of course don't forget
even when the Lords passes amendments to
the bill it goes back to the Commons who
then have to think about whether they
want to accept them or not
I mean you say that you're expecting a
strong to be you must also surely be
expecting to lose on a number of votes
given the balance of that well I'm not a
defeatist now I'm going to go in hoping
that the government's case will be won
hoping that we can persuade their
Lordships of our case but as I've said
why there are constructive suggestions
about
improvements that need to be made to the
bill we will be ready to listen and we
will work with their Lordships house to
make sure that this bill gets back to
the Commons in an excellent state it
sounds to me almost like you're
considering down there sevens that the
state in which the bill has reached the
upper house is not a fit state that
actually there are areas in which it
could be improved and you're simply
going to have to accept that well as
I've said we made the government
listened in the House of Commons
amendments were made there we've also
said that we ourselves will be bringing
forward amendments and I certainly
accept discussions to happen
I expect the bill to be amended I'm
clear about that but what I also expect
is that we will send the bill to the
Commons in a good state because what we
all want this bill is about ensuring
that we have a law laws that work once
we leave brexit we all want to make sure
that our legal system is in the best
state it can be and we will all work
together to achieve that but for all the
talk of strong debate and to talk of
amendments that you that you've been
mentioning I mean in essence what you
are seeing is that the government's
vision of brexit as espoused in the EU
withdrawal bill will not be the one that
has returned from the upper chamber I
mean if the lords act as they say they
will to block your vision of brexit for
that is what they are doing I mean how
far would you go Frank field had an
interesting suggestion on this program
at the other week when he suggested you
know having the threat the sword of
Damocles of their cutting hundreds of
members of the upper house might be
something that would compel them to to
vote in a more amenable fashion to be
honest we've heard all these
speculations before this was exactly
what commentators said when we had the
article 50 bill oh no the Lord's will
record oh no the laws will behave on
unconstitutionally that didn't happen
the Lord scrutinized the bill we sent a
couple of changes back to the comments
to consider but the comment said thank
you very much House of Lords but no we
want this bill in the state that we sent
it it came back to us and the House of
Lords did what it does which is respect
the primacy of the House of Commons you
don't detect that you might be about to
enter into a fairly lengthy game of
parliamentary ping-pong on this
particular issue well as I said I know
it's going to be a challenge I'm not I'm
not I'm not disputing that but what I do
believe is that the Lord's will enter
this in a constructive manner we will
have strong debate I think will the bill
will be amended but we will work with
the house of laws to make sure that a
better
arrives in the House of Commons the
House of Commons will then consider that
changes the House of Lords have made but
it will be for them then to decide
whether they want to accept them or
whether they want to send the bill back
to the House of Lords and say thank you
very much but no and the House of Lords
will respect its role and will respect
the primacy of the House of Commons and
we will ensure that we have a legal
system that is fit for purpose on the
day after we leave the EU which is what
we all want to work towards just in
terms of the possibility of reform of
the House of Lords I mean it is pretty
clear that it's in brass thick need of
it isn't it and once again we have a
former MP no Ben noble Danji Lansley
it's apparently selling his access to a
Chinese fun what an earth is he up to
well we have very clear code of conduct
in the House of Lords and very clear
guidelines about what is acceptable and
not acceptable behavior Andrew Lansley
has referred himself to the
parliamentary Commissioner for standards
which is the right thing to do she will
investigate and we shall wait to see
what the result of her investigation is
but on a regular basis the House of
Lords does an excellent job I'm very
proud to be the leader of the laws and I
think we will show ourselves in a good
light over the next few weeks when we
scrutinize and revise very important
legislation and make sure that we have a
legal system fit for purpose for when we
leave the EU should we just focus on
Andrew Lansley for just a second are we
not at a point where it might just be an
idea for our politicians not to take
outside work when they're working either
in the House of Commons of the House of
Lords and what does it benefit us well
to have someone like Andrew Lansley with
the experience that he does essentially
selling his skillset to a foreign base
of foreign based company well as I said
we have a very clear code of conduct in
the house of laws we have very clear
well as I as I've said we have very
clear register of interest we have a
code of conduct and as I said the
parliamentary Commissioner for standards
in the House of Lords will be looking
into what happened I am not privy to
what conversations took place but it
will be investigated and if action needs
to be taken from there it will really
the right person to be leading the
charge in the House of Lords I mean
you're appointed last year to many of
yours and and my peers by surprise
Andrew Pearce quoted one saying evidence
is over debt
need a big hits her with brexit
legislation she was put there because
she was Nick Timothy's Chum it's why her
days are numbered I mean are you Nick
Timothy's Chum is that why you're there
well thank you for your confidence
nearly it's greatly appreciated
I actually think if you don't mind me
saying I'm doing a good job in the House
of Lords I think I'm a different face of
the House of Lords I hope your viewers
will double take when they see me think
oh gosh she's she's leader of the Lord's
is she we are a changing face we are
revising chamber I think I'm doing a
good job and I look forward to leading
this bill through the Lord's and I look
forward to the constructive discussions
which will happen with my colleagues
across the house we've become very fond
in the shoe of asking what Labor's
position on brexit is this week I mean
the Tories we have to say I've become
similarly all over the shop of late and
you've got the Chancellor telling Davos
this week the changes to the EU UK
relationship would be very modest
I mean is that is that vision of BRICS
that you'll be advocating in the Lord's
we've been the prime ministers been very
clear and set out in her Florence speech
our vision for our future relationship
with the European Union and we're little
just be 100% clear the Chancellor's
wrong when he says that the changes to
our relationship with the EU will be
very modest we've been very clear about
our relationship and future partnership
with the EU we want a strong and deep
partnership and that is what we will be
working towards but what I'm going to be
focusing on in the House of Lords is
making sure that we pass a bill that is
very important to make sure there are no
holes in our laws once we leave the EU
that is important work it is work that
the House of Lords will do it very well
I have no doubt and I look forward to
the weeks ahead I mean it still sounds
like you're saying that the Chancellor
is wrong I mean another thing that's
imagine the people's today your brexit
negotiator is suggesting they're willing
to have a longer transition period than
two years I mean import where is that
delivering brexit well it again the
Prime Minister and indeed David Davis on
Friday have been very clear once again
we do expect an implementation period
and we think it will be important
because we want to make sure we give
businesses and people certainty and to
make sure we have one set of changes and
we've been very clear that that will be
for a two-year bill so it's it's not
going to be extended beyond the sort of
lost it's not you're back again there we
are it you absolutely clear on this that
any suggestion that will be an extension
to the transition period beyond two
years it's just not a flyer it's not
going to happen I'm sorry I had a bit of
a tech
hitch during that question so I didn't
hear the whole question but as I as I
will repeat and say once again we have
said that we're anticipating a two-year
implementation period the Prime
Minister's been clear about and David
Davis once again reiterated that on
Friday can we talk to the Director of
Public Prosecutions for a second Allison
Saunders no as you'll be very well aware
she's ordered a review of all rape and
serious sexual assault cases to see if
there are any problems with disclosure
of evidence she expects even ahead of
this review that there will be a number
of cases that will have to be halted
because of the problems with disclosure
that's an absolute disgrace isn't it
well was it false what CPS or the police
what's absolutely important is that
people have confidence in our justice
system that's what we all want to work
for we'll have to see what happens with
this review but what we don't want a
miscarriages of justice and we don't
want victims to also not be served by
the system so it's absolutely an
important balance to be taken right and
I think we need to make sure we look
into this to ensure that we can and the
public do have confidence in our justice
system our legal system is there was a
report produced by the CPS Inspectorate
back in July of 2017 which said the
process of recording details of
sensitive material is routinely pure the
revelation by police to the prosecutor
of material that may undermine the
prosecution case or assist the defense
case is where the standards Fogel it
falls below any acceptable standard of
performance that was 7 months ago there
is no need for a review the problems
with disclosure have been well known and
there are most likely people in prison
right now who should not be well I'm not
going to speculate on on that I don't
feel I can but what I can assure your
viewers is that we take all these issues
extremely seriously my colleague David
got very problem for seven months
how is that taking it seriously well we
are taking it very seriously we do not
want to see miscarriages miscarriages of
justice but we also want to make sure
that victims have a fair system with
which to go through that is what we're
working towards and we will be working
with the legal profession with the
police with the CPS to make sure that
the public can rightly have confidence
in our justice system because that's
what we all want to achieve
I mean I'll say it again the problems
regarding disclosure not simply in rape
cases and serious sexual abuse cases but
across the board have been no no for
many years and have been identified by
the Inspectorate since July of last year
so whose fault is this
is it the police is that the CPS or is a
succession of Justice secretaries
conservative ones at that well I don't
think me casting around aspersions is
going to help anyone it's not going to
help the victims of miscarriages of
justice and it's not going to help
victims who actually want to bring their
case forward what we need to do is move
forward we need to make sure that the
public have confidence in our justice
system and that is what we're all
working towards baños Evans lovely to
speak to you thanks for joining us thank
you very much